do you fear and PTSD your time with CAA
I have nightmares
sure flashbacks
so how did that translate into the work
you're actually doing I am I can't talk
about operational work so I don't think
it really I don't think there's really a
way to answer that without talking about
shifting from this kind of work to that
kind of work do you know what I mean
[Music]
when you leave the agency you go through
a long process of having your cover
rolled back and I'm able to talk about
having worked there but obviously not in
the details of any particular operation
in my early 20s they created an
algorithm to predict areas in the world
that would give rise to terrorist
activity
I wanted to deconstruct what it is that
creates terrorism
[Music]
spending years in another country where
nobody knows what you do or who you
really are as as lonely I mean it's
lonely in
the small moments really as much as the
big moments you can't really have honest
or frank conversation even in your own
home because of surveillance and being
listened to and watched
[Music]
I did see things that I'll never be able
to unsee humans not seeing the humanity
in other humans whether that's torture
or killings that are undertaken with the
same kind of callousness as a butcher
might take to a piece of meat
[Music]
is there a coyote in here house money
dreams
when I get some breakfast
[Music]
as a parent you know is my greatest
responsibility to go out and make the
world
a more safe and peaceful place for my
daughter to inherit or is it to be at
home snug with her reading Harry Potter
and the world she inherits began
hey John it's amaryllis were you able to
get the Kurdish authority on the phone
about the deed change I'm a little
worried with all the build-up around
Mosul I want to make sure we're
conflicting with the Iraqi military yeah
try DC ain't give me a ring back okay I
[Music]
have created an organization called
Operation Zoe Zoe Manning life and also
being my daughter's name I wanted to
take former military officers and
intelligence officers who have all
learned very specialized skills in order
to wage war and allow them to use those
specialized skills in order to wage
peace George hi my friend I would love
to see you
nobody's Kurdish is like your Kurdish I
think we're gonna have at least a night
in Erbil and we'll stay in the Ratana
because their security is amazing
and their security team is trained by US
forces they've got double blast walls
snipers on the roof so I feel pretty
good about that you could meet us there
inshallah I think one of the greatest
lessons that I took away from my career
at the agency is this underlying truth
that everybody believes they are the
good guy and for many people in Syria
and Iraq and Pakistan and Yemen and
Somalia and other places where we're
flying drones the idea of being kept
safe by American sky robots that kill
people without making a sound is as
upsetting and driving as much desire for
conflict in the Islamic world as the
atrocities that we see Isis committing
is driving in the American world
kimchi Musa Shing GTN do you know what
TN me and split heaven or the sky teach
and I travel so frequently but it's
never routine you know it's the minute
that you find a routine that you stop
being aware and stop taking precautions
when you're on the ground it knows you
and I get home underdog so so so so much
I'll talk to you tonight okay love
[Music]
my sweetest coyote more than anything I
wish I could hold you as you read those
I wish I could wrap you up in my arms
and tell you how you're my best friend
and why is this teacher
I wish I could leave you this snugged in
our bed with the world of day outside
our window and only love around us
but I'm writing you this letter in case
I can't in case I've been stopped or
hurt or killed in case it's only my love
and not my arms that hold you tonight
okay
I want to explain why I've put myself in
danger why I've risked a lifetime of
telling stories with you in the park
as you grew deep beneath my navel I felt
all of humanity inside you
the truth is all over this tiny speck in
space we humans are the same craving of
love of understanding of being heard and
seen
[Music]
can we just go to SFO International
Terminal please
[Music]
things can change in a heartbeat you
don't know who is manning the checkpoint
cases they're managed by the Iraqi
military and other cases by extremist
groups who are operating locally
checkpoint three
obviously yes I have in Virginia oh I
stay here
[Music]
speaking kurdish and we'll get out grab
our ad for him
the aim of this trip is to spend time
with Syrian and Iraqi young people who
have all lost family to the fighting and
had put together reconciliation programs
to build trust with one another again
[Music]
to be in the energy of these kids who've
seen such savagery and just so much
passion and intellectual curiosity about
what it is they can do to make sure that
this doesn't happen again on their watch
at least in their country at least for
their generation they're committed to
peace
[Music]
we're ten years plus into one narrative
about the war on terrorism and it's very
binary what we're doing is not bringing
an end to this conflict
ever since I was little I've really
loved this Rumi poem out beyond ideas of
wrongdoing and rate doing there is a
field I'll meet you there I love that
idea because the more that I was out in
the field the more I realized that the
question is almost always not who's
right and who's wrong almost always both
sides are partially right and it's
important for us to be able to put
ourselves in our adversaries shoes and
invite them to put themselves in our
shoes so that we understand what is
driving this conflict or it goes on
forever
[Music]
every single person that you meet is
made out of star stuff
what a beautiful stars up the dark night
sky
people turning out the lights little me
down Oh flowers
cities go
[Music]
and with you now as you read this and
always in every breath
do not fear the darkness you have in
your heart the brightest of lanterns let
your love fill you with warmth that you
might fill others and they still others
until the world is lit from your heart
you are the love of my life your mama
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh
you
you